only we talked to drew about the
challenges
of launching a brand new talk show
during a pandemic
how's it been putting a show together at
the craziest of times
i'm not gonna lie there was a lot of
tears there was a lot of
doubt uh that we would ever really
happen please welcome drew barrymore
i've been waiting all my life to meet
you i am not playing a character
this is the first job i've had where i
really get to utterly be myself
and i would have never been right for
this job until this moment
here we go everybody have a great show
i think i'm at probably the most settled
place in my life i'm a mom i can see
things from a lot of different angles
and i still have enough energy because i
mean i went to work at 11 months old
when does this tire i'm like what what
why am i still this energized i'm so
excited i could scream
wanna do it with me guys ready
what can you expect from drew's new
daytime talk show which debuts september
14th
a bit of fun with pop culture beauty
secrets help my weird hormonal breakouts
and funny sketches kind of like snl
which she first hosted
when she was just seven years old i'm a
berrymart
get me a drink and make it a double
you're gonna have laughs aren't you well
if i didn't have comedy in my life i'm
not so sure i'd be standing here or
sitting here
you can also be sure the drew will bring
in her celeb friends like reese
witherspoon nicole richie gwyneth
paltrow and bestie
cameron diaz how different is it being
the interviewer now for you
because you've done a thousand of these
so you've you've had a lot of bad
interviews
i think it's really weird when people
choose to do a profession but they're
like you can't know anything about me
i'm like then you chose the wrong
job it's fair game something else that
drew wants to do differently
her team behind the camera will also be
a part of the show
i really want to peel the layers back
and show what a show is who makes it how
does it work
i will never call this my show this is
our
show when it comes to hot topics nothing
will be off limit
that includes drew's single status and
her two daughters seven-year-old olive
and six-year-old frankie
you also are a mom how do you handle and
balance that
they see it all they get that i'm you
know
baggy sweat pants you know mom and
they get that this is my job and what i
do
the only thing i care about in this
world is that they know they come first
i understood that when they were born
that that was the purpose of my life
can we show you something because this
is you at seven
on et do you think it's hard or easy
being so young and being an actress
well
it's fun it's not that hard though
it's easy it's medium
that's crazy it's so weird to watch
yourself because
i can see frankie my six-year-old
in the facial expressions and like the
weird like mick jagger-isms like
and then i see olive's face
and we look so much alike the circle of
[Music]
life